do you miss me like I'm the lot peace be
with you this is a greeting of all the
messengers of God including Jesus Moses
Abraham in the last final messenger
problem i'm at peace be upon him somehow
you got to this show the Dean show is
dedicated to clearing up the confusion
clearing up the fog there's a lot of
junk in the trunk we got to move it out
of the way there's a precious treasure
there there's a precious treasure and
many people are distorting the truth the
opponents of this truth and you hear a
lot of Arabic terms that are thrown out
d hot holy war like some Cowboys coming
to get you the boogeyman Sharia oh my
god and welcome the Muslim next door do
I gotta run door I gotta hide what do I
gotta do here do I get my shotgun and
put on the white mass now I'm out trying
to lynch these people because they're
trying to take away my freedom no no
silly it's not about that muslims are
those who are seeking peace with the
crater within themselves and with the
rest of humanity and with my next guest
we're going to give you some evidences
of proof to clear up this confusion so
you can rest assured that Islam is not
with the others that you've heard out
there in the media it's not about that
and you might even want to accept this
beautiful way of life that guarantees
you success in this life and definitely
success in paradise in the next sit
tight don't know don't go nowhere we'll
be right back this is the theme the
danger
this is the video this is the things is
the danger
this is the thing you know this is the
things of the theme jus this is the
thing is danger this is the video this
is the please be up to you peace be unto
you brother Josh Evans how you doing
good very good at hamdulillah all praise
to the one true creator how are you good
good time to LA thank God you won't find
the people who are praising the crater
more than those who call themselves
muslims a good times bad times we're
always saying thank God thank God
absolutely I tell us is Joshua Evan's
Evan's does that have anything to do
with bob evans i don't think so it was a
good restaurant know you heard about it
great taste on the phone a great taste
on the phone I don't know maybe
somewhere in the lineage jihad holy war
you hear this all around the media you
know Muslims Sharia and many people are
even coming out you know openly saying
look Islam is the problem Islam is the
problem they're trying to take away our
freedom you know these backwards Muslims
are just trying to take away everything
that we've developed and we're a
developed nation and these people are
backward and just try to you know do
things backwards and they want to press
the women and put them behind this this
veil this is a topic that we're going to
be talking about today so tell us have
you also you know been kind of feeling
this that these things that are out
there what are your thoughts it's it's
it's a very unfortunate fact that you
know after a certain amount of things
have been put forward that this is what
you should be afraid of from Islam
Muslims that it's kind of boiling down
now to where the real issues are coming
out that Islam is the problem the Quran
is the problem that the jihad is a
problem that the Sharia is a problem the
real issues in tenants of Islam are now
being pointed out the problem but the
only real problem with that is there
being distorted those teachings and
parts and parcels of Islam are being
distorted outside of their they're
realistic teachings to be put as an
ideology that we should be afraid of and
this is the problem is that the
information is being distorted so that
when the
get this information it no longer looks
like Islam where they're calling Islam
after it is delivered to the people
through the mass media it has been
churned up and twisted so much that the
final product does not even look like
it's lamb anymore that's what we really
need to deal with whether it's Islam or
whether it's not Islam very simple now
you had just not too long ago someone
who got who had international media
exposure and attention and someone who
had like 20 what is it 25 followers and
then he got out there on the microphone
and the media just just you know gave
him all the attention and this the same
way we can say that those who have some
extreme views there are my nephew and
the media gives all them their attention
so you can see like you know you can use
this and see how like when and this
doesn't because you had Christian I'm
talking about this Jerry Barry Jones was
talking about burning the koran and you
had Christians Jews other people who
from other religions who came out say
day this guy you know he don't represent
us and he was talking about burning the
koran what were your thoughts on this
yeah he actually talked about burning
the quran didn't go with ahead with it
and then finally did go ahead with
putting the Quran on trial and then they
burnt one copy yeah I mean realistically
it just shows the profound ignorance not
only of some people but the profound
ignorance of the media you know to to
even give a platform to this ideology
and to this type of rhetoric we have to
ask what is their intention because
Terry Jones was some guy unknown in a
small area not too far from I used to
live in Florida that had a follower
following that you could find that any
bus stop here in Chicago you know so was
it like he had some massive audience and
then the media gave him this massive
audience it just shows that that he was
trying to put some attention to himself
and put in his attention on what he
wanted to say Islam as a buck I've been
really reality he did nothing wrong as
far as in his efforts to burn the quran
things that I nature none of that was
wrong but his intentions to make Islam
look so violent with the thing that
we're really concerned I heard one of
our good friends sheikh yusuf estes that
he was saying look you know we can we
can give you some of the oldies
the Quran is unchanged untampered with
Tampa free tamper proof in the original
Arabic but you might have some you know
some pages missing you might have some
miss prints by human being making human
errors I heard the Sheikh was saying
look we'll send you some of these you
know it'd be a pleasure you can burn
these up yes when we spoke to terry
jones yeah you know we kind of tried to
take the air as argument very quickly
yeah let him know the first and foremost
what you're doing is not impermissible
in slam one of the permissible was the
most recommended way to get rid of a
Quran whether it has become old or
damaged or some misprint aware visit to
burn it and and also if you're trying to
set a precedence you're about 1400 years
too late because the the third caliph of
Islam of men the third Khalifa did this
a long time ago when he codified and
said these are the authorized versions
of the Quran and everything else that is
trying to be put out there we're going
to burn it and destroy it so he did that
he burned a large number of quran's so
that there would be one codified way
that the way the Prophet Muhammad peace
be on him talk so I told her we told him
you're far far too late you're not the
first to do this no are you doing
anything in permissible will send your
lobes if you want loads we can call up
all the messages and the mosque in North
America in the world and say if you had
some old crimes you wanna get rid of
cinema Terry Jones let him burn him he
could have done it it seemed like people
would be more upset the intention behind
it would just like trying to find a way
when you want to work towards peace with
someone you'll find a common ground
you'll find a platform a ground a solid
foundation that you can work towards his
peace but it seemed like he was just
more about steering up negativity
bashing Islam this bigotry this hatred
it seemed like okay the Japanese at one
time with the enemies then the African
Americans and now the Muslims you know
now the Muslim these are the opponents
these are the other yes these are the
others what he was trying to do and what
a lot of people try to do the media try
to do is build barriers because the
truth is a dangerous thing it's a
dangerous tool not dangerous in a
negative sense but dangerous and the
fact that it enlightens people it gives
people a sense of new awareness and and
if you don't want people to be exposed
to a truth that
may change the whole scheme of the
system and enlighten people that you
build barriers and this is what this
attempted to do build barriers between
the truth and between the people and
we're going to talk more about the truth
we're going to ask very important
questions that are the minds of the
people I'm the Masters here in the Dean
show will be right back with Joshua
Evans sit tight and go nowhere def and
the day of judgment the mercy of Allah
these are the things that finally made
me realize there is no time to delay
anymore I wanted to take Marshall harder
right there great the essence of
spirituality is to become more sincere
to Allah span without much of a decade
so it is very very scary but it brings
you back to reality there is a life
which is everlasting and you have to
make a conscious decision or which a
group of people do you want to be the
people in heaven or the people of I am
not afraid to stand alone if Eliza
I am not afraid to stand alone i am not
afraid to stand alone if Eliza by my
side I am not afraid to stand alone
back here on the Dean show and we really
want to encourage people get people
excited to work towards peace to work
towards an understanding with your
neighbor with your Muslim neighbor at
that if he's Muslim get to know him let
me take you out to some biryani or a
milkshake or what ask him these tough
questions does and we're going to ask
you one of those tough questions this
guy buried Jerry Terry Jones whatever
his name was that he said that he wanted
to put the crown on trial so if you have
a Muslim neighbor go and ask your Muslim
neighbor does this Quran call you to
kill me as a Christian does it call you
to kill me as a Jew does it call you to
cause this havoc on earth does it I'm
asking you right now absolutely not you
know the ideas put forward to the Quran
is a book full of violence and the book
full of tyranny and oppressive teachings
which if we go to what the Quran teaches
the like I said the information the
truth is rarely available the main come
complex of the Quran the main portion of
the Quran is the teachings that God is
one this is the majority of the teachers
of the Quran about God's oneness the
second largest majority of the Quran
teachings are about the day of judgment
the day which we will have to stand in
front of our Creator and give a count
for our actions and the third largest is
the stories of the prophets the stories
have no stories of Moses of David of
Abraham of Jesus all of them peace be
upon all of them and then the smallest
portion of the Quran is the teachings of
rules and regulations which are talking
about where to talk about of the Sharia
and in that isn't my new portions
talking about the rules and regulations
of war and within those rules
regulations of war are things that do
teach non non aggression towards
innocent people you cannot kill
innocence you cannot kill women and
children and all of these things that we
are going to put forward to the audience
are in there but the Quran is not a
violent book that the truth is there for
anyone to go pick it up it's not some
book that is hidden and you only certain
people can read it no you can go and get
it and read it for yourself and make
your own decisions this is we know
that's testified by over 1.5 billion
people this is the verbatim word of God
is one version of the card is that right
in version one version and it's in the
arabic guy could have revealed it in
french or in German but he chose because
this Arabic language that we can go on
to another show it doesn't
that is elevating the Arab now does it
there is a religion for the Arab this is
a book that is for the whole of mankind
and it talks about these things and I
had one person because so many people
are coming to Islam one person he was
new to Islam and then he'll hear some of
these things and he came to me and you
can go ahead and tell me if you've had a
similar situation he said look Eddie it
says here you know I heard this person
he quoted me the verse and it talked
about I think it was chapter 9 sewer
nine and 29 something like that about
fighting and I just said look do
something a general rule read the verse
before and after and then he it was
cleared up he was an odd man that just
just made my heart settle because he was
a little scared now what I get myself
into have you had this similar situation
happened what advice do you have people
also they'll hear these verses thrown
around context context right yes we see
a lot of versions are taken out of
context a lot of verses of the Quran
taken out of context or completely
mistranslated or misquoted and for
someone to do that it is very much an
injustice and a disservice to two truths
and a disservice to the book into the
religion itself even if a Muslim does it
even if a Muslim takes the quranic
context there are a lot of Sciences
behind understanding what is netbook we
have to understand what is the context
you need to understand the language you
need to understand the basic tenants and
teachings of Islam so that you don't
misunderstand a verse of the Quran all
of these things go into play this is why
in Islam we refer to the scholars and
let them tell us what Islam is is and
what Islam is not and when we do that we
get a clearer painted picture and this
is the thing that they are saying that
the scholars are not doing the Imams are
not doing they're not telling people
what Islam is about that's very much
untrue it's the fact that they're not
going to those people to find out what
is the real information they're talking
to the layman and Joe you know whoever
in Terry Barry and they're letting these
people tell the story go to the people
who know the religion asked in the total
story you get a completely different
picture we've had so many several
several scholars on the show also people
like yourself clearly condemn it acts
like 911 we got to keep going over this
shoe bomber underwear
her the envelope bomber whatever
g-string bomber these things are
contrary to Islam Islam says don't kill
women don't kill children don't kill the
old people this LOM is about peas people
with yourself peace with the creator of
the heavens and earth and peace with the
rest of humanity and people are getting
to learn all this and more here the Dean
show continuing on tell us now jihad I
mentioned it and they translate it which
obviously mistranslation it's not your
holy war talk to us about this word
jihad well jihad jihad does not mean
holy war whatsoever and jihad I don't
even know what it means a very very
flagrant way of trying to say he like
the Cowboys from the Western I know
jihad needs to be understood in its
context as well jihad is an Arabic word
that means to strive it a struggle to do
something and that could be many things
if they build a building let's say in
Arabic they would say they did you hood
you know they did you had to put this
building above struggles it was hard but
if we want to go to the definition of
jihad itself wherever we find jihad in
the Quran or any derivative of the word
jihad whenever we find jihad in the
statements of the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him it is understood as a
physical struggle and as a internal
struggle to seek the pleasure of God to
make God's oneness known on the earth
and also to eradicate injustice to
eradicate oppression to eradicate
tyranny and to eradicate terrorism on
the globe this is jihad jihad is an
attempt and a struggle to establish
peace on the earth justice for all human
beings so that no one has to fear for
their life so no one has to fear for
their safety so that everyone is taken
care of financially economically
socially so that everyone's rights are
afforded to them under the system of law
that was given to them by God jihad is
an attempt to do that so for someone to
say that jihad is to kill innocent
people it's very contradictory to the
teaching itself the teaching itself
would say no that there if there is
someone who seeks to kill innocent
people jihad would mandate that I
stopped them that I stopped them if
someone was tyrannizing other people
jihad mandates that I try to stop them
even if it be my own self even if it be
my brother in its
or my blood brother or my father or my
mother it necessary sensit eights that i
try to establish justice freedom and
free people from oppression and tyranny
now also obviously look does Islam give
you the right to defend yourself to do
jihad against the person who tries to
commit injustice towards you let's say
he tries to rob you come in your house
stick you up try to rape your wife you
know you jihad against this person to
get them out to protect your loved ones
is this surely that's logical not that
is logical that that self-preservation
is in tuned into our psyche it is
embedded into our psyche to preserve
myself and to preserve that which I love
and my family and my property so a
Muslim is is not allowed you know in the
religion he is told or she is told to
defend oneself that's my honor this is
my person my family my property my land
whatever I own it is my right to make
sure that it is safe and if I have to
defend someone defend myself against
someone trying to take that or put that
in danger then I have afforded every
right to do so and this is logical this
is very much rational ideology so is it
also struggling and striving to be noble
to be righteous against those evil
inclinations let's say those evil things
inside the desires sometimes to tame
these desires so you're not at the
nightclubs on the weekend you're not
using profanity you're not hooking up
with that lady outside of marriage and
you're not being promiscuous showing all
the cleavage and be naked out there
prostituting yourself you know looking
for all that negative attention and
you're doing jihad to be modest to be
Noble to be righteous to speak good
words to be good to your family to your
parents not to be disrespectful that
that is jihad is it or is it not
absolutely to try to be a Muslim which
we spoke about in a previous episode
which a Muslim is someone who tries to
do Islam that is a jihad struggling
everyday to please the Creator to make
myself a better human being to forward
myself as a better person in society as
a more educated person as trying to obey
my parents those are all considered
jihad as well I'm
I a mother trying to take care of her
children is considered as you had a
woman who gives birth is considered
that's considered jihad to speak the
truth is considered jihad there are so
many things which when we put them in a
kana in the proper context of what is
your head then it becomes very clear
that what the media representatives you
had is very much not you had before we
go to break did Jesus the Christ the
Messiah who we love no Muslim as a
Muslim unless he believes in Jesus did
he do jihad the Moses do jihad that they
teach in priest jihad absolutely they
all struggled to make sure that the
truth go forward and Jesus himself
suffered greatly because of trying to
put forward the truth and this is
considered a jihad to try to put forward
the truth so that humanity can know a
right way to worship and live in front
of God is jihad let's take a break and
be right back with more here on the Dean
shall sit tight oh can you put your
dream home and you've got your dream car
but you're going to get old and things
are going to happen to you in your life
and then what have you got at the end of
the day it's an empty dream that has no
real foundation we are going to die and
we're going to meet our Lord and he is
going to judge us it becomes an
obligation for each single human being
to find out what the Quran is Islam is
telling us to stay away from things
which are bad for your person in bed for
the society it's killing of innocent
human beings human life is precious
there always be someone there will be
there to say something negative but at
the same time there'll be someone there
to say something positive awesome just
hold on to the Rope of Allah everything
in this universe real I I need a last
minute the court answers don't kill
women don't kill children don't kill old
people don't attack the civilians this
is what the Prophet Muhammad told us it
will fail your marginal gossip that the
prophet saw silent never ever start a
war against anybody and if we're going
to worship something I figured I might
as well worship the Creator instead of
any of the creations now in upon
investigating the villages I remember
finding out the meaning of what Islam is
what Muslim is those who surrender
yourself to God is a Muslim those who
surrender submit to God God's will Daisy
Islam was pure it was just you just pray
to God your Creator back here on the
Dean show and we're clearing up all the
confusion many people are there a little
bit timid a little bit scared but you
know people are good you know we have we
have good people in this society you
know there are neighbors our co-workers
and the same thing they go to the Muslim
physician you know Muslims are our
doctors scientists you know the
engineers you know your your cab driver
and good law-abiding citizens but we
also adhere to the law of God yes the
law of God doesn't call us to kill
innocent people it doesn't cause us to
to do tyranny and oppression and all
this other nonsense so you hear people
like you know we don't hate them we just
don't want that over here right and some
of the big cities Chicago New York you
know people are intelligent they see
through all the baloney but in some of
these other cities they it seems like
there's a little more misconceptions
there's a little more confusion so
another term okay we cleared up jihad
another one Sharia and this is I
compared to like the boogey man's coming
to get you and they start to pass laws
that you know you can't have Sharia here
and this and that define for us Sharia
what it is and what it's all about and
did Moses and Jesus teach Sharia
now our we did touch on Sharia what a
minute was a way to leading to God's
pleasure yeah and that all the prophets
did have a shitty away a codified law
but but Sharia in Islam if we wanted to
kind of give it a synopsis what is the
the ultimate goals of the Sharia and
Islam the ultimate goals the Sri in
Islam are to see that society lives a
just and righteous life before God to
see that everyone has afforded their
proper rice no one goes hungry no one
goes without food no one goes without
shelter no one goes without their daily
expenses of life that necessitates them
to be able to be a productive human
being and all of these things are within
the Sharia and I've done many lectures
last people would you like in law that
is codified to give every human being
their rights and it needs no amendments
it needs no adjustments that make sure
there's no racism they make sure there's
no oppression there's no sexism there's
there's there's no prostitution there's
no gambling where people are getting you
know stealing other people's money
there's no interest bassist and more
people the rich are continually to get
rich off the backs of the poor all of
these good things and mostly like yes
this is a very good system I said this
is the Sharia this is the Sharia this
comes to seek about this means to bring
society to the closest it can get to a
utopia because it is designed by the
creator itself this is not a law that
Muhammad peace be upon it made up
there's not a law that scholars make up
no this is a law design by the creator
of human beings if he designed them put
them on this earth to worship Him
therefore he must according to logic and
according to justice design a system for
them to accomplish that goal and this is
the Sharia and so for people to say that
the Sheree is something that you should
be afraid of we have to ask them okay
well then what is it that you afraid of
about the Sharia is it you're afraid
that the system of tyranny and the
economics rich getting rich off the poor
are you afraid the sure you will bring
it into that are you afraid that sure
you will bring it into the drug problem
in America or in the west of the
prostitution problem of the gambling
problem of the homelessness if that's
what you're afraid of them yes the
Sharia comes to that is something you
should be afraid of but if someone is a
Justice loving freedom loving individual
than the idea of a Sharia law of a God
made
system should be a welcomed ideology to
them and many like-minded people of many
faiths who have looked at the Sharia in
an unbiased way have come out publicly
and stated that this is a good system
and that if it were to be implemented it
would not bring about any type of
tyranny or oppression it would be a good
thing well note one note you'll hear
people like to share oppresses women
what you got to say about that actually
this is very illogical because if we
look at the society today and we walk
out here in the streets of Chicago or
New York and a city and we look at how
women are treated they're already in a
state of oppression the way that they
are dealt with by their beauty they have
to flaunt themselves and and kind of you
know expose themselves as something that
they're not in order to gain some
respect with inside the world this in
Islam is oppression for a woman to have
to live that type of way in Islam gives
women the afforded right and actually a
great ripe that she is an individual
issues that be dealt with as an
individual according to our intelligence
according to her personality according
to how righteous she is and she is dealt
with in that manner nothing to do with
anything that she can offer to me to
look at her glare at none of this is in
Islam this is actually a breaking the
code in Islam to to flaunt oneself in
this type of manner so as lamb gives
women due rights that we don't even find
in the society we live and now gives
them more rights and we see who women to
convert to Islam which is the majority
of converts coming to Islam are women
they'll say that they feel more secure
and safe now inside the religion of
Islam than they ever felt out in the
streets this is amazing it's amazing and
Islam really uplifts the woman gives her
these rights that you know it was
unheard of when people were debating if
a woman had the church was actually
debating whether the woman had a soul in
the she had a solo wasn't it Islam was
elevating the woman to a status rice
that she just got in this country isn't
that and when actually if someone was to
take and look at let's let's take a
scenario of men and women relationships
and minimum and marriages if they were
to look at the rights between the men
and women they would actually see that
and if you talk to most Muslim women
that they get the better end of the deal
in most cases when it comes to any law
women get afforded the majority of
Rights and actually men are more
responsible they don't have as many
rights as they do is responsibilities
and women have a lot of the rights and
and and this is not to say it's an
unjust and unbalanced it's just women
gives them that status that they deserve
yeah they're structured there's
completion here no guesswork this is
another proof about Islam that is from
the crater because everything is laid
out from A to Z you can run the world
with this way of life that only makes
sense the Creator wouldn't separate
himself from what he created meaning
that you say he figured it out on your
own you know and leave you in a state of
confusion he sent messengers these
messengers taught preached and teach
what the purpose of life is how to run
your lives according to his will not
your desires and if you live it you get
peace paradise in the next life success
in this and everything is getting to get
cleared up and it is really amazing
amazing and we can go on and on talking
about the the women and their rights and
what I suggest usually is to talk to the
Muslim woman you talk to her doctor go
finally asked her woman with a job who
Mary the mother of Jesus some of the
most noblewomen they're dressing
modestly because they choose to up dress
not take it all off you know they just
need to go find it i mean we see that
very clearly and i know we don't have
much time but you know they just passed
the burqa ban and france and if it was
and they pass i said because it's being
forced upon the women yeah then why are
the women fighting against the band yes
being women how do I should be
celebrating in the street but no the
women are the ones who are fighting
against this band sang it's my choice
it's my right this is my dignity so if
Islam oppresses women why are they the
one fighting for their own rights in a
non Muslim society to have their Islamic
values and let's separate culture you
have some Muslims with the name tag and
they'll go ahead and do like what's
honor killings has nothing to do with
Islam they'll go ahead and and and do
some oppression that's culture separated
from the true teachings of Islam
absolutely Islam is codified there is
nothing in Islam that is missing so if I
add anything to it I've made a mistake
if i subtract anything to it i've made a
mistake so we need to know what Islam is
and then clear up all these myths and
clear up all these misconceptions and
set the record straight what Islam is
and what its name is now
be unfair if we didn't invite him to
Islam we got one minute left talk to him
tell them what Islam is in the
invitation of Islam and how they can be
by implementing Islam in this light day
for me because is successful and have
peace in this life and paradise in the
next talk to him very clearly Islam is a
continual striving to submit yourself to
the one true creator of all that exists
that God that created you in the womb of
your mother and submitting to him on his
terms doing what he wants you to do in
your life living a life that is
righteous before him and there will also
lead you to be righteous in the world in
the society and to live in peace and
harmony with all human beings and
someone who does that is a Muslim
someone who does Islam and becoming a
Muslim is very simple there's no ritual
you don't have to go and you know take
some big huge ritual and ceremony and
inductions and no very simply if you
come to an agreement with inside
yourself that there is one true God that
is worthy of worship and you decide to
worship Him the way he wants to be
worshipped believing in all the
messengers of God starting from adam to
know what to moses the david did jesus
to muhammad peace be upon all of them
you make that statement i believe that
there's one true God worthy of worship
and I believe in the Prophet Mohammed
and all the messengers of God before him
then simply you are a Muslim and you
strive every day to try to please the
one true creator god then we if more
people did that we would see a much more
peaceful and a much more functioning
Society and much more better individuals
thank you very much we started with
peace my brother and we end with peace
peace peace be unto you think me and to
you is my pleasure always my pleasure to
be thank you very much may God Almighty
the Creator Allah reward you thank you
thank you very much I truly thank you I
thank you for taking time to tune into
the Dean show I know there's a lot of
entertainment out there many things that
are striking us all the r-rated movies
you have all the x-rated movies take a
time out from all this stuff not saying
you're doing it but some are many are
and you're gambling and drink in and all
the other things that don't bring peace
in your life there's no purpose they're
fulfilling what fulfilling what chasing
your desires from this nightclub to that
nightclub from chasing man this man that
woman and you're not really reflecting
about the purpose of life and the
reality of death there's going to be a
dead judgment that's the day that
preparing for and your good deeds are
going to be a testimony of your faith
what did you believe in did you testify
it through actions and that foundation
is built on the worship of the one God
worshipping him alone not his creation
that God is not a man or a woman but
he's a crater of man and woman and then
developing yourself to be the best human
being that you can be Islam is not
calling you to blow yourself up and blow
up innocent people it's not that is not
the teachings of Islam Islam is calling
you to have peace within yourself but
first you got to have peace with the
owner of peace and then you can have
peace with the rest of humanity you've
learned something very very important
today and you learn more continue to
tune in here to the D show and until
next time peace be unto you